alright guys so here we are downtown st.
Catharines as you can see there is a lot
of polka stops and they definitely are a
lot of gems as well and we've heard that
this place is a gold line for catch
pokemon so we're definitely excited
alright guys right now me and Tara are
gonna take over this trim there's like
for valor guys and you know it feels
let's think we might even let it go but
not Fowler
fatality alright guys so we just took it
over and now we saw like a place with a
bunch of leurs so we're just going to go
over there hopefully got some cool
pokemon so we're approaching the loads
as you can see and just as we're
approaching it already get a TV and a
mantle it around so that bodes well now
let's catch these guys and keep going
see if we get any rebel alright guys so
we got to the lures and we're all
chilling here at the park with the park
altera monovalent park montebello part
and i were just gonna chill here the
lures are going and we're gonna let you
know if you catch anything good we're
just happy to be honest to get some
shade finally
so guys there's this one spot right here
where magica keeps on popping up this is
the fifth time already it's popped up
other than that we haven't seen anything
crazy but magic or but I hope that in
the upcoming episodes will actually get
a gyarados i think it's possible so
we're gonna go all right now grab some
either pizza or subway we haven't
decided you guys will figure it out and
then we're gonna get some ice cream you
know recharge have a good day it's a
beautiful day right now chillin in the
park was fun celebrates his birthday and
so we leave pizza details to find ice
cream for Tara cuz we want to make Sarah
happy it's so good you said we can taste
we all giddy like apparently apparently
she wants to get a vegan ice cream I was
like and she's not vegan she just thinks
the face really good okay hilarious I
don't know I don't know you gonna escape
it's like why don't you just slap me in
the face okay guys we got the vegan ice
cream how is a mass pretty good i can't
complain these these are you satisfied
the chocolate is very buggy I think
that's a good sleep
it tastes like regular choc ice cream
so st. Catharines definitely I was a lot
of focus tops if you ever want to
restock on both balls and potions but it
wasn't great for both wanted a all we
got was an abra and a number of magic
card but my first day back to school
made up for that I've been telling you
guys how good Brock is for poke bomb but
this day was crazier than any other day
I didn't have my video camera with me
but it caught a Charmander a graveler
caught two air dactyls so I can power up
my strongest one and found another
dragonite another one watch what happens
I can like ah Gareth or borrow two
thousand years later
and just like that I got it with a great
ball it's insane how difficult is a
catcher Dragonite animat couldn't even
catch it he wasted all his pokeballs I
don't know how we did it but we did it
we caught a second dragonite
unbelievable now let's go do some
evolution I guys now gonna do some
evolutions alright and we're just kind
of coughing coughing showed up at my
house right before we started filming so
there I just caught it and now she's
gonna have enough for a wheezing and I
have like quite a few evolutions to do
i'm going to use lucky egg and power up
to level 26 but there are five
particular evolutions we're gonna do
like a variation of the delete challenge
we're like you guess the CP the one who
comes closest gets a point and in the
end who gets the most points the other
person has to delete a Pokemon except
with it we're not deleting Pokemon
because you know we love our pokemon so
we're gonna actually just argue about
like what movie we're gonna see I get
the pic if it's me it's gonna be an
anime silver spoon i'm watching it's
pretty hilarious and she wants to watch
Peter Pan if she wins so let's see what
happens okay so slow poke is the first
one so 776 CP what are you guessing
galleria guess 1600 oh I'm not saying
seventeen hundred and twenty that's
insane and can i steam that's pretty
cool you think you're closer yeah so
that was a lie on her part alright cool
one nothing right next is a clefairy
that's 736 CP what are you guessing 1415
okay i'm gonna guess 1550 let's see what
it is fifteen thirty eight hours closer
and thailand as ugly we're still looking
for pound and moonblast less best musa
but still pretty cool strong so two
nothing for me and light there can we do
more than just five hustle please they
don't want to watch all of my evolution
yeah we can do it off canyon if you guys
like this one let us know we'll do more
in the future so this one we're doing
dinner and all the way to the final
evolution so i guess we'll have more
than five altogether guesses this one's
516 it around so this is gonna be like I
think a really good that opium so soon
nice 516 okay 990 i miss a 1050
you might get this 19 is a good guess
licensure I could send you right now no
I can't cuz there's some it all together
with the net around
whoo not nearly as strong as I thought
so Terrell is right to uh nice to all
right what's the next one
okay i'm gonna say 1600 1668 nice 31
like I know let it be disappointment
that you're doing but really I don't
know might an earthquake that's cool
alright so now I'm never
first 15 23 what's it gonna be 9 NB okay
I guess 900 alright guys so the knitter
and Nidorino was lower than 900 so I got
that one so it's for one for me now but
to keep it interesting
Pikachu holy Sh how did that come up
okay well we're gonna actually catch
this pikachu brief intermission cool is
this a perfect way if it just finish off
the day it's catching food I'm gonna
like really it was like are you willing
I like you are my tickle its letter
alright guys so we did catch that
Pikachu good job now we're gonna get
back to some evolutions we're gonna do a
few more we're going to do two more
evolutions so you still have a chance
okay
I just I know we're not gonna be
watching Peter Pan and don't give up
it's cool you could get this okay it's
79 every oh ok what do you think 15 20
I think that's exactly what I guess okay
I'll say
I'll say 14 50 60 and 33 you got it but
I'm still happy because that's like
that's a good mood let's see we're gonna
do sign up now you've had more sign next
to me she has more gold dust than me so
you should be better than this one all
right thirteen 13 15 13 17 1350 final
I'll say
I'll say 1500 know you got some i keep
getting psychic move sounds like I want
to get a water got on hydro pump but
it's okay cool this is interesting now
it's 43 all right all right what else
we're gonna do we're gonna do a shelter
what do you think it's gonna be it's 463
i'm going to say 40 hundreds ep 1400 ago
tekzilla quick look at my quest no you
can't no I think it's gonna be told
hundra okay
this could be yet this could be a bigger
gamez
what wats that is so weak I'm shocked
okay cool so this is 44 all right time
break a wish happy birthday wish what
would you do we'd like to do it again
I've never seen it I can't open folder
back okay i'm gonna guess 900 950 950
what did you say 950 Wow almost exactly
alright guys hate to admit it like no
one thought this would happen just
brushing on me but Tara one this one so
we're going to be watching Peter band
night and I'm going to finish doing
these evolutions we're going to be level
26 by the end of it and then we'll see
you next episode where hopefully we'll
get a polygraph so we're get through
dallying or product into a bio pool next
episode it's gonna be fun and gyarados
is coming up sooner or later all right
it's coming